[Music]
the Irish border question can be solved
without having a hard physical border I
don't think my visiting the border is
really going to give me a fundamental
insight into the border beyond what one
can get by studying it surprise when you
sent you to power I thought it'd be
interesting I hadn't visited the border
between the United Kingdom and the
Republic of Ireland and therefore it
seemed an interesting thing to do I
think one can perfectly well understand
issues without making a physical visit
do you think the realities that can
Santa
white might change your mind but it's
worth sensible to be able to possibility
of changing one's mind but I wouldn't
put money on
so I'm Majid that maybe there's people
on the border who are transported
livestock or whatever
we'll be really worried about some sort
of
or to Garen are you can understand that
you can understand people being
concerned because there's a lack of
clarity about what the position is
while they wait for that clarity the
farmers who work these lands fill in
enter the soft border they see is
crucial to their business sheep when
cattle farmer John Sheridan is based in
the north
he's known locally for strong anti
brexit views on paper that is managed
away from the border discussed on PM's
what I'm saying at yeah but what I'm
saying at the moment of practicalities
of even just a simple me lorry
delivering military yard it comes out of
Donegal it comes out of Donegal Jacob
yeah alright but people delivering mail
will still have to meet the standards of
the country that they're living living
tip so you just depend completely under
paperwork then we do anyway no not
necessary yes you do I just asked you
both just because you've met each other
you know what do you make of each other
have you been pleasantly surprised oh
gosh no I'm looking at Jacob leaks in
log nearly every day a very articulate
con man that can put his kiss very very
well of course what you think Jacob
Jesus does it's much changed your view
it's very interesting to come here and
see how the border physically works and
how it Wiggles back and forth course
attendance but I think the
practicalities of continuing as we are
are very straightforward if there's the
political will to do it we move on to
the nearby border town of Black Lion in
the local pub shin famed supporter Chris
McCaffrey lives and works on opposite
sides of the border to him Westminster
decision-makers are a world away the
people here on on the border would feel
a burden and conservative Theresa May
and this conservative government don't
understand just how important areas
border problem and
because I think Jacob understand well
I'm glad to see that you're actually go
riding and trying to have a discussion
and figure further into the village a
more relaxed view Harold so checkpoints
come and go he thinks the border is only
ever as hard as the communities here
choose to make it it doesn't matter
because there's one's there was Eustace
maudlin and if it's cheap here the
winner to the north and it is cheap and
they're not there in it here create a
lot of employment as he walks with me
along the border for the final time on
our visit
what has this brexit ear learned you
said before UK that you didn't think
that come in would give you any more
fundamental understanding of the issues
of the communities on the borders if you
changed your view after meeting some
people today it's been very interesting
to meet people and to hear what their
specific concerns but the big principle
is that here's this road behind me which
goes from the Republic of Ireland into
the United Kingdom and the question is
can this road be kept open
and the UK government by saying it will
keep it open Seoul's half of the problem
and the challenge then is for the Irish
government and the EU to say in return
we will keep our half of the border
apron and that issue has not changed
from before I came to being here
mystery smoke what's the Prime Minister
to face doubling down but brinksmanship
on the matter of Ireland is not the card
she wants to play she wants a compromise
all can live with it feels a long way
off